This is very a little bit suspicious for
me. Yes?
He's walking down the road.
He carries out the attack. I want you
guys to watch carefully to the car black
car
right there. Right there.
Right there. Do you see that? Is that a
police car?
If you care about the dunya more than
the akhira, skip it. By one donation,
you're going to help 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people who've been fed
through the emergency food aid. You are
going to be sponsoring 4,200 orphans.
You will be helping 250,000 people in
Gaza. You'll be helping 123,000 people
to be fed through our food program. You
will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 massages are going to be built around
the world. And 74,000 given clean safe
water. That's why we want to keep one
ummah 100% donation policy. And in order
for us to keep 100, we need you to help
us by supporting this fund so that all
of the stuff that I mentioned, you get
the reward for every single one of them.
It's far more important than the dunya.
And you will see every penny that you
give on Yawm al-Qiyamah. The decision is
yours. The link is there. So, it is
being reported that two Jewish innocent
individuals were stabbed by an absolute
absolute maniac. And again, the word
terrorist was used by the likes of Tommy
Robinson. We're going to go on X and go
through the timeline of who's posting
what and see what it is. Firstly, number
one, this is absolutely atrocious. This
is disgusting. And you're going to see
what the far right
posting out there. And Tommy Robinson is
keeping it a bit safe. He's calling it a
terrorist. But it it depends, you know,
if it's it's being careful. If he calls
him a Muslim, then he's been embarrassed
so many times when it's turned out not
to be a Muslim. So, he looks like an
absolute idiot [__] He has to use a
cocaine addict who's spending charity
money on his
um son's watches. Anyways, Rolex
watches. By his mate, we're going to go
to his his his calling it terrorism. But
I don't know if he would apply that if
the perpetrator was Jewish or was a
Zionist or was a Christian or a Hindu or
a Sikh for that matter. Would he still
stick to that label? No, he's keeping it
safe. He's calling it a terrorist. And
then when it comes out, he will say,
"Ah, Muslim terrorist." So, this is the
uh moment. It says absolute horrific
scenes from Golders Green.
So, this is the perpetrator, this
culprit. He starts attacking this
innocent Jewish man who's standing
there. Who is standing there? And thank
God the people Now, one thing I want to
notice is this guy.
If you've noticed, this is where I I
want to know
this is very a little bit suspicious for
me. Yes?
He's walking down the road.
He carries out the attack. I want you
guys to watch carefully to the car black
car
right there. Right there.
Right there. Do you see that? Is that a
police car? Is that a marked police car
or a marked police car?
That looks like one of those undercover
cars.
How are they there for the It's It's How
I look, I'm just asking questions.
How are they there so fast as soon as
the attack happens and they are
intervening? I don't know what's going
on. I don't know if that was a marked
car. I don't know whoever that person
was, how did they from that distance
I'll just rewind a bit.
This is where this scumbag starts
attacking the innocent Jewish person.
Yes, as you can see it's happening. And
then you've got this car over here
automatically in the I don't know if it
was a police car or whatever, yeah? But
I don't know if from that distance cuz
you've got a car in front of you to This
car was in the way for you to see from
here what's going on. So, I don't know.
But anyways, here's another footage
of this vile man walking on the streets
of Golders Green and looking for someone
who he comes across this man.
Footage shows
foot Sorry, further footage shows of the
stabbing stabber chasing Jews down the
streets in Golders Green. Two men were
stabbed, one in his 70s and the other in
his 30s. And thank God this Jewish man
got away by this from this vile man.
Then we've got another post. There was a
confrontation. Golders Green has always
been my favorite place in London, just
10 minutes drive from my home. It's
calm, welcoming neighborhood with the
streets strong Jewish community. And
it's such a piece of community to come
under attack again is truly breaking.
Thank God. And now, over here, obviously
I I have to blur this for uh
sensitivity. The officers are kicking
him in the head. Now,
I am I'm I'm going to be more shocked if
people pay attention to what the
officers are doing in this I'm I'm I'm
doing their job. With all due respect,
I'm so sorry. A you knife-wielding man
who has stabbed two uh two individuals
and has been tased and is still holding
to the knife. I'm so sorry. With all due
respect, that's the least they can do.
Those police officers did their absolute
phenomenal job by putting this cowardly
individual down, which we don't know his
motives are. And I'll be honest with
you. Um
I'm not for violence, but kicking his
head to maybe cause him to be
unconscious till they grab the knife
because he could stab them. He could he
could stab them for that uh So, I hope
no one comes out condemning the police
officers. Okay. Again, Britain Broken,
uh probably far right page, I don't
know. Footage shows Golders Green man
being tased, kicked in the head, and
arrested after being after the two
Jewish people. Now, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to go a bit more. Um this
is where the confrontation happened. Uh
and here is the man. So, this is the man
in question. Here it says, "Here's the
people He He's the Here
He's the people responsible today's
attacks in Golders Green. Okay, I think
it's here here. Here he is, not he's.
Here. Okay, your time for accountability
is coming. We will never forget. Okay.
So, um there we go. So, they've taken
accountability to Sadiq Khan,
Keir Starmer, this officer, and the man
in question. So, this is the man himself
who, as you can see, uh is wearing a
glasses. We do not know
what
uh background he's from. Irrelevant,
crime is a
Yeah, there we go. So, now what I'm
going to do is guys, I'm going to go to
Tommy Robinson's. As you know, he's like
to make the most out of it. And he is
happy when attacks happen against
innocent uh civilians because it serves
his agenda. It serves his propaganda. It
serves his agenda. So, let's go to And
this is the Jewish uh Jewish Chronicle.
Um as you can see, uh who, if I'm not
mistaken, are pro-Zionist. Who who will
not We we condemn all anyone that's been
killed or for that matter or been
attacked. They will not ever I don't
think the Jewish Chronicle has ever
claimed that what's going on in Israel
is a genocide. When it's happening to
the Palestinians, and we condemn it all.
If I was here making a video and telling
you guys, "You know what? Most likely
that person did that attack because of
No, no, there's no excuse for anyone
trying to
murder anyone, assassinate anyone, carry
acts of terrorism towards anyone. But
guess what? Guess what? The far right,
they're not like us Muslims because
we're morally consistent. They don't say
that. Here it goes. Golders Green
stabbing updates according to Shomrim,
that's the that's the police officer
They have their own police. Yeah? A
volunteer-run neighborhood watch
organization entrusted this cassette
cassette areas. One male suspect was
seen running around Golders Green armed
with a knife attempting to stab Jewish
members of the public. A medical
helicopter has arrived on the scene.
This is a developing story. So, we don't
know the motive. The individual is
arrested. So, this is the video.
There you go. There you go. Appalling.
Appalling.
Uh okay, there we go. Again, terror
attack. Two Jews have stabbed in Golders
Green, London. This suspect has been
arrested. Nothing is yet known about the
severity of the injuries.
Strength to the Jewish community. Yes,
and I hope the Jewish community are kept
safe away from these barbarians, whoever
they are attacking innocent Jewish
people going about their life. And this
can happen to anybody. You had a Sikh
woman walking and was followed by a
scumbag who thought he was she was a
Muslim and raped her. Yes, okay. This
happens, you know. Subhan Allah. So, I
want to go to Let's go to Tommy
Robinson's page. Let's see what Tommy
had to say.
There we go.
The cokehead. Okay.
So, there we go. So, what did he here
say? "This is the moment the terrorist
is taken down after stabbing the Jewish
people in Golders Green. This is England
2026. Union Jack flying proudly by the
British Jews as an invader scumbag who
likely hates everything British attacks
them." Okay. So, there you go. He's very
careful to his wording now because
before he'd be like, "Muslim this,
Muslim that." And he realized it's not a
Muslim. It's not a Muslim. And he looks
like an absolute [__] So, that's the
reason why he took he's taking that um
Again, CCTV shows the moment of terror
starts his attack in Golders Green
stabbing the first Jewish victim in
though throughout several times.
So, now let's go to the comments of
this. Let's see what the comments are
saying cuz this is where it gets
interesting.
Why the F are they kicking him? They
already uh
Really? You are more concerned about
them kicking him. For God's sake, come
on. What in the world is wrong with
these people?
Okay, meanwhile in Germany, migrant
allegedly sexually assaulted a young
underage girl. German police attempt to
arrest him. Dozens of migrants run to
his attack and let go. Same
bigoted narrative, as you can see. Okay.
Made up mostly of fake stories, by the
way. Give it a week and the police will
either be suspended or again, I I I'm
I'm 100% what I'm saying. This is
This is unacceptable that the officers
are doing their job and they're going to
be suspended for what? A knife-wielding
maniac. Yes, okay.
The Jewish hate on social media is
getting too much and I think the
government should do something about it.
Is it? What about when there was
Islamophobia? Did you guys speak about
it when there was Islamophobia and
Muslims being attacked on the street?
You see this issue with the double
standards and the hypocrisy you guys
have. The absolute double standards and
hypocrisy you have. When Muslims
innocent Muslims, men, women, children
were being attacked on the streets in
the Western world in Europe, you didn't
say that. You didn't say you didn't even
deem that as Islamophobia. But why is it
selective outrage? Why? You do not even
call it a genocide what's happening in
Gaza. Over 70,000
mainly women and children massacred,
babies.
Do you say anything? Because you guys
are scums. Cuz you don't care about
human life. Don't come to us and play
the victim or selective outrage. Do you
say the same and condemn what Israel is
doing? No, you will find excuses for
that. The Jews are doing that because
they're being attacked. Would you apply
the same behavior to this terrorist and
say, "He done A because of B"? No.
The hypocrisy. And that's why it
shouldn't be. I'm 100% to that. They run
like little girls. Just shoot him in the
head.
Now, he will be released in a few days
by leftist judge. Wow, police are
allowed to kick people in the face in
the UK. Look at Look at I mean, guys,
where is your priorities? Like
seriously.
Your police can kick suspect in the head
while he's down, but can't shoot him. Do
they wear steel
boots? Well, there you go. Yeah? And
then we've got the the scumbag Moazzam
There you go. Yes? Good boy, Tommy. Make
another 15 posts about it. It's not like
your friends imported these
these savages in the first place. Okay.
There you go. Subhanallah in a nutshell.
And there you go, Mossad does his friend
there Mossad who finances his campaigns.
And
and and don't forget that Mossad is
connected to the Epstein Island where
those white girls are being raped so the
elites can look that the Mossad was
using them, the white girls that you
really care about, you know, raped so
they can use it against the elites,
blackmail them so they can go to war by
sending those white servicemen, okay,
men and
women to go fight for them and die for
them. And here is your proud Mossad
clown, the Tommy Robinson, the scum of
the earth as you can see, the absolute
coward. So I mean look, in a nutshell
guys, you can see what's been going on.
Again, the key factor is this. Is
anything spoken about a
Look at this.
This one, yeah? Texas woman accused of
attempting to drown Muslim children.
Yes? Okay. There you go. Texas woman.
Not a Zionist. She wasn't a Jew. No, no,
no, no, no, no. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no. No, no, no, no, no. Okay. Drunk
woman tried to drown 3-year-old and her
toddler. Look, look, look. Did you hear
about this?
Look, you will not hear about it.
Yeah?
You will not hear about it. Okay. The
attacks that happened to Muslims, yes,
Palestinians in Israel, in America, the
shootings that happened, yes, Zionists
who carry out attacks against innocent
Muslims, okay? They don't talk about
their faith. They don't talk about their
religion. They do not even connect it to
their scripture. Nothing. But when it is
a We don't know who the suspect is. If
he's a Muslim, whatever it is for that
matter.
The moment they find out his faith is
that You know why it's sickening?
Because they do not care about the
victims. They just want to know if the
culprit is a Muslim or a migrant. How
sick do you have to be that you do not
condemn the act, but you are rather
concerned about who
the perpetrator is. That means you don't
care about the victim.
You are more concerned about who the
perpetrator is. So it's so it's a
narrative. And there's many examples of
this. That's what I wanted to say to you
guys inshallah. Wanted to bring this to
your attention. And we hope that the
Jewish community are kept safe and
vigilant. And any Muslims out there that
you see any human being being attacked,
be they Jewish, be they whoever. And and
so much so, so much so I'll say this,
yes, that even if they're a Zionist,
that's this those dirtbags that we
we confronted in Golders Green who were
justifying the killing of innocent men,
women, and children. If you see them
being attacked,
defend them. Yes? If you see these
people, their family members, whatever
it is for that matter, defend them
because they are not our teachers. Do
not be like them and say, "Oh, no, no,
no." Our job Our teacher is the Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him. And he told
us And lowest form of iman is if you see
a harmful thing on the road,
remove it. And fantastic job done by the
officers and those who intervened. Till
next time. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.